[Music]
archbishop emeritus desmond tutu asked
for a simple ceremony
a low-key funeral for a plain-spoken man
and the nation did its best
[Music]
the arch as he was known was carried in
a simple coffin as the cathedral choir
sang a hymn
but there was no honor guard on display
nor great flowery bouquets
and there were just a hundred in
attendance due to covert rules
but tutu is the object of limitless
affection
and his daughter naomi gave her thanks
because we shared him with the world
you shared part of the love you held for
him
with us
we say
thank you
daddy
for the many ways you showed us love
for the many times
you challenged us
for the many times
you comforted us
the south african government called it a
category one funeral a solemn event of
remembrance
but as the president began the eulogy he
told the country to cheer itself up
that's what tutu would have wanted
if
arch
bishop desmond duty were here
he would have said hey
hey why are you looking so glam
so unhappy
he would have wanted to elicit a smile
and laughter
from amongst all of us
that was the type of person that he was
but tutu also led the fight against
white minority rule in the 1980s and
played a pivotal role in the creation of
a new rainbow nation
helping us to come to terms with the
past
was among the most arduous tasks
of our new nation
and archbishop desmond tutu
played a seminal role in this whole
process
while our beloved madiba was the father
of our democracy
archbishop desmond tutu
was the spiritual father
of our new nation we will be free
appointed archbishop of cape town in
1986 desmond tutu took on the
politicians and police of the apartheid
regime
and he remained an uncomfortable
opponent for the country's leaders in
the democratic era
tutu spoke truth to power wherever he
found it and he was given the nobel
peace prize for his efforts
he never ceased to speak prophetically
he never ceased to speak powerfully he
never ceased to shed light
many nobel prize winners like fades with
time his group writer
his simple coffin made from the cheapest
pine was carried from the cathedral by
the leaders of the church before his
body was taken for an environmentally
friendly cremation
a modest man desmond tutu has left an
extraordinary legacy
john sparks sky news